wow
[Music]
[Music]
god
[Music]
more
[Music]
that is a gorgeous spot
oh
oh that's a lot of snow
so
[Music]
oh we just survived
[Music]
it's tradition to forget at least one
thing every camp out and i forgot to
bring a knife
luckily i keep my hatchets pretty sharp
so we're in good shape she doesn't taste
very good it just tastes like
all right we got the fire going next we
got to get our cots in here get the
plates all nice and cozy
absolutely
hey
is that plenty warm yes i'm super warm
i'm sweating in here
oh
[Music]
got some water melting here
i got snow melting on the stove we got
the boys all nice and warm i need to
start drying up their clothes so i'm
going to string up a little uh
clothesline here
you're gonna put a sock up there wet
socks was telling this
pronounce my name they could call me
that's frozen
a letter
so it's it would be like
no is it
your name
sun sets really early up here so uh
we're gonna get hunkered down here
pretty quick it's gonna get dark but uh
we're gonna make some dinner and uh i've
got some fun things we're gonna do
tonight kind of pass the time this is
gonna be a nice little out oh it is so
hot in here
you know i'm gonna open the window up i
am
you guys hungry yeah so guys i love
gourmet cooking on these camp outs but
bringing all the equipment and
ingredients and prepping it out in the
field is a bit of a pain so what i did
is i took this mason jar and last night
i just threw in some raw beef and
seasoned it a little bit of beef broth
got tomatoes potatoes carrots onions
green onions beans i got some sage and
basil and cilantro and other seasonings
in here just threw it all in the mason
jar
and uh we're just gonna boil this thing
until we get beef stew
just gonna sit it in this water and
we're just going to go ahead and let
that boil
pretty much all i'm doing is canning
beef stew on a camp out if you want you
can just go ahead and seal up the jar
and then go put it on your shelf for a
couple months and then anytime you want
you've got heat and serve beef stew
ready to go it's only been about an hour
all your clothes are bone dry look at it
feel those socks
that worked great
well this is our first time using this
tent it's made by arctic oven and it's
the igloo and i believe it's the warmest
tent in the world and i believe it this
thing is like a sauna in here i need to
start stripping down layers but i really
want to use this in some extreme winter
camping this winter so this is kind of a
test run i don't know if you can see it
but right there
the floor is turning a little black
the stove is actually charring the the
floor mat so i gotta do something to fix
it and i think my best solution is i
need to raise
the uh the firebox up i think because
the feet are sagged down into the snow a
little bit it's uh it's causing some
problems
hopefully that'll fix it and we won't
burn our uh our floor mat it is so warm
in here we're just sitting with the the
door open and we're still like stripping
down
oh
we are going to be plenty warm tonight
it's not just a stove that makes this
warm this is a really beefy double
layered tent i mean look at this it's
like quilt material
i mean this stuff is really thick and
heavy this thing is really warm even
without the stove we also have this
thick canvas ground mat which is highly
durable so you don't tear up the bottom
of your tent and it also helps insulate
and keep the cold from the ground from
coming up too much if we keep the fire
on
all night we don't even need sleeping
bags yeah
[Music]
now that we're kind of settled in for
the night i got my boots off and laid
down a caribou hide so we can walk
around in our socks who wants a pillow
all right there we go
there's my pillow i need to go ahead and
text mommy and let her know we're safe
and warm this is the garmin inreach mini
and it's hooked up to the iridium
satellite network allows me to send and
receive text messages by satellite since
we have no cell service here it also has
a tracking feature so that every 10
minutes it sends my location to a
website and becca can log in at any time
and see where we're at and if we don't
check in she knows exactly where we are
nice looking good since we have several
hours before bedtime
i figured we'd read a book together and
so i got a bunch of paperback jack
london novels here and i thought it'd be
something really fun to read to the boys
hey guys what do you want to read do you
want to read call of the wild or white
fang what thanks white fang all right on
the sled securely lashed was a long and
narrow oblong box in advance of the dogs
on wide snow shoes toiled a man at the
rear of the sled toiled a second man on
the sled in the box lay a third man
whose toil was over a man whom the wild
had conquered and beaten down until he
would never more struggle again oh guys
you want something warm to drink
okay check it out we're gonna have some
hot tang we used to drink this a lot as
a kid so i was around during the cavemen
[Music]
oh that's good
is it hot
oh give it nathan a sip give it a sip
hot tang we used to drink that on winter
camp outs all the time hot tang tastes a
little bit like waffle or you know kind
of a spiced apple cider
that's looking
really good
look at that that looks amazing
that's perfect
[Music]
yeah it's yummy but hot
[Music]
all right
there we go did the dishes
for dessert we've got brownies and this
is just a basic betty crocker box mix
throw it in these little mason jars and
we're gonna go ahead and cook it just
like we did the stew
you want to make sure you fill this up
only about two thirds full because the
brownies will expand a little bit we're
gonna put the brownies in the water just
like that
well elevating the firebox and closing
the flue a little bit seems to have done
the trick and uh we're not getting these
scorch marks anymore but i think i gotta
come up with some better solution than
that for the future use hey guys the
brownies are almost ready you guys want
me to make some ice cream yes we got
some vanilla extract some sweetened
condensed milk and a bowl full of snow
just go like that
that is some delicious vanilla ice cream
right there
isn't that a beautiful brownie
oh
brownie and vanilla ice cream you guys
ready yes
is that good
you like that dog
ice cream the best now for breakfast in
the morning i've got coffee cake batter
in a mason jar
and i've got a homemade bread pudding so
i'm going to go ahead and throw them in
now and cook them for several hours and
that way by the time we get them in the
morning they should be nice and done and
warm
these boys are gonna be so warm tonight
tommy's in a negative 60 bag this is the
snowy owl by feathered friends it's the
warmest sleeping bag in the world and
then nathan down here is in the negative
25 bag my feathered friends it's also an
amazing bag
it's gonna be crazy warm i'm worried
about you being too warm all right guys
it's getting close to your bedtime you
guys need to go use the potty yes
do you want to go outside in the cold no
what what are we going to do then mason
jar
[Laughter]
toothpaste is kind of thick well it's
not quite frozen it's just it's a little
thick though yeah it's chewy
at the front of the dog sled and at the
rear un awed and indomitable toiled the
two men who are not yet dead oh i just
heard some popping sounds
[Music]
yeah i i filled up the coffee cakes a
little too full
they popped their lids off
looks like you only want to fill them
about half full not two-thirds
it'll still taste
they begun auspiciously they lost no
dogs during the night and they swung out
onto the trail and into the silence the
darkness and the cold the spirits that
were fairly light love you guys you
didn't get some sleep okay no
no
no i think we need to get some sleep
good night
fine
no no
good morning
it's nice in here well it's about 8 30
in the morning and we've got about two
hours before sunrise but we have a cozy
little fire and i moved that pot on it
and it's just been kind of simmering
away and we should have some fresh warm
breakfast ready good morning nathan
you sleep well
oh
he is
he's way down in his burrow that boy
knows how to burrow into a sleeping bag
we're gonna try the bread pudding
bread pudding is like one of my favorite
things check out that bread pudding that
is done perfect if you guys don't know
what bread pudding is it's kind of like
french toast casserole with raisins i
just put all the ingredients in the jar
sealed it up then boiled it
you know cooking brownies or coffee cake
or bread pudding in a mason jar like
this takes a lot of time at least two
hours
but the good part is is you can't really
overdo it so if you've got this stove in
the tent anyways and it's just going to
be running
might as well throw some jars in
whenever you're ready to eat it it's
done it's ready to go i think this one's
probably boiled for six hours
and uh it's not overdone at all
but check out this is one of the bread
puddings and it's just absolutely done
perfect and you can tell it's done
because there's a gap on the sides bread
pudding shrinks when you cook it coffee
cake expands this is the one coffee cake
jar that didn't explode hopefully it's
not going to pop on me
oh look at that
oh yeah that is good looking you guys
wouldn't like this it's no good
[Music]
oh yeah you like that
this is amazing
[Music]
all right guys 10 30 in the morning the
sun's coming up the moon's setting
what a beautiful view
it is definitely colder today but one
good thing about it it froze the trail
solid so i don't need snowshoes today
[Music]
[Music]
ah the poles are frozen
i was setting up the tent i got some
snow on the poles and it's melted and
now it's refroze that's gonna be a
hassle all right one problem at a time
well it's been a bit of work but a what
a lovely spot
look at this
it's gorgeous
we'll take these poles back the car see
if we can defrost them
you guys want to go back to the car and
do some awesome sledding
what is it do you guys want to do some
[ __ ] yeah
you got air tom go run him over
guys i hope you enjoyed this video as
much as we enjoyed filming it if you
guys want to see more adventures from
the outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning and we
have an entire playlist of our camping
adventures with over 50 videos make sure
to check that out we'll put a link in
the video description below we'll see
you guys next saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]